the ESG and climate change crowd has
absolutely lost their minds remember
this is the same people who convinced
multiple countries to give up their
energy Independence and to trust Russia
well that didn't work out so well and so
now these Geniuses these Galaxy brains
are now turning all of their attention
to the Bitcoin Network now ultimately
what they are doing is they announced
this morning a brand new campaign that
campaign is called change the code not
the climate it's a catchy headline but
what they are talking about not only is
impossible but it makes zero sense now
to understand this there's a number of
different ESG groups and climate change
organizations that have come together
they've got about five million dollars
in funding from Chris Larson as well
Chris Larson is the co-founder of Ripple
he's had a long story in history in the
technology industry the campaign
specifically has a couple of key points
first the campaign wants to buy ads in
leading Publications over about a
month's time period they want to
pressure the Bitcoin Community to alter
the way it orders transactions so quite
literally get the big Bitcoin Community
to change the code and the campaign
beliefs inaccurately that about 50 key
miners crypto exchanges and core
developers have the power to change
bitcoin's code this not only is
impossible but it shows that the ESG and
climate change crowd they don't even
understand how Bitcoin works there are
no developers or crypto exchanges or
even miners who can go ahead and change
that code this was previously tried when
more than 50 of the hash rate got
together during the block size Wars and
the node operators threw their middle
finger to them and kicked them out now
ultimately these folks are gonna try it
they're gonna spend millions and
millions of dollars they might as well
just flush it down the toilet because
there's no way this is going to work but
we've got a quote here from one of the
leaders of the Sierra group one of these
ESG groups and he says we are in this
campaign for the Long Haul but we are
hoping particularly since Bitcoin is now
being financed by entities and
individuals who care about climate
change that we can compel leadership to
agree that this is a problem that needs
to be addressed he continued by saying
Goldman Sachs BlackRock PayPal venmo
Fidelity there are lots of companies we
anticipate will be helpful to this
effort well unfortunately the Sierra
group may not understand but Goldman
Sachs BlackRock Fidelity venmo PayPal
Etc they're not the leaders of Bitcoin
nobody can change the code no matter how
much money you have no matter how much
you yell and scream you cannot change
the code unless you get the developers
the miners and the node operators to all
come to agreement now we've got another
quote from Chris Larson where he said
that if he was concerned about Bitcoin
as a competitor probably the best thing
I could do is to continue on this path
this is just an unsustainable path well
unfortunately when you listen to
somebody who's not in second third or
fourth place but instead they're so far
down coin market cap that they can't
find where Bitcoin is at the top because
the market has determined Bitcoin is the
most valuable cryptocurrency because at
the end of the day cryptocurrencies
their value is derived from their
security and Bitcoin is the most secure
Computing Network in the world it's all
rooted in proof of work so nobody's
worried about what the second third
fourth fifth sixth seventh eighth ninth
or tenth competitor thinks about number
one the number one cryptocurrency is
worried about winning and that's exactly
what it's doing now of course there is
the coin shares folks they had a great
quote where they stated that they'd put
the chance of Bitcoin ever move moving
to proof of stake at exactly zero
percent there's no appetite among
bitcoiners to destroy the security of
the protocol by making such a move and
Chris is dead on with that comment and
then of course I couldn't stop without
mentioning my good friend Nick Carter
who had the perfect tweet to go ahead
and sum this up what he said was as a
Bitcoin node operator and a member of
the Bitcoin High priesthood that
controls the protocol I have duly
considered Ripples and green pieces of
requests to eliminate proof of work from
Bitcoin and I hereby dot dot dot deny it
well ladies and gentlemen that is
exactly how I feel as well these folks
can spend millions of dollars they can
Surface all sorts of inaccurate data
they can run and scream all they want
about all of the fun that they've
created but the end of the day Bitcoin
is the most secure Computing Network in
the world it's based on proof of work
consensus mechanism Bitcoin will not
change that consensus mechanism and the
reason is not only because bitcoiners
understand security not only because
they understand and the importance of
decentralization but they also realize
the market is determined Bitcoin is the
most valuable protocol in the world why
would we ever change what's working hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time